[Musique]
élégante et filer la rhubarbe se fait
belle mais pas seulement au début de
l'été la voilà qui nous fait de l'oeil
pour encore quelques mois
question de faire durer le plaisir
avant sur leur barbe fine c'est aux
alentours du 15 juillet mais maintenant
avec l'irrigation on est capable d'avoir
des rebelles jusqu'au mois d'octobre
ça fait combien de temps ce vous avez vu
ces changements c'est depuis que la
fraise d'automne est apparu logique
quinzaine d'années c'est vraiment ce qui
est fait qu'on a une demande de
poursuivre d'emballer de la rhubarbe 13
et rhubarbe
voilà deux inséparables leur union se
décline en confiture compote et
l'incontournable tarte à la base létale
durban vient de la firme de mon arrière
grand parent de la barre avoir fait que
les plans de grammont plus cassantes
waouh bienvenue chez les fermes serbie à
saint-eustache
sébastien et sa soeur marie-eve font
partie d'une famille qui cultive la
rhubarbe depuis cinq générations
ils sont les plus grands producteurs du
québec on peut emballer une grosse
journée l'autre 500 boîtes de barbe
c'est environ 2 millions de tiges par
annick est emballé aux fermes serbie
disponible dans 3 grandes bannières
d'épicerie au québec la rhubarbe serbie
se vend en paquets de neuf bâtons qu'on
appelle aussi piquionne et pourquoi 9 je
sais pas dans le temps de mon père c'est
comme ça depuis des années on est resté
sous la marque de commerce de neuf
bâtons de barres belle dans les champs
la rhubarbe devient une oeuvre d'art
lorsque façonné par la pâtissière
stéphanie la bête à la pâtisserie
rhubarbe sur le plateau mont royal aime
la réinvente en version sucrée
alors que son conjoint le chef julier
j'aurai la décline en version salée au
comptoir ruban
donc je dirais que c'est plus ma copine
ma blonde qui aime vraiment beaucoup la
rhubarbe et je suis tombé amoureux aussi
de la rhubarbe en partie à cause d'elle
le chef nous propose d'abord une
création
j'essaie travail et la rhubarbe avec des
saveurs d'afrique du nord à tajine suis
parce que c'est vraiment la cuisine truc
du nord méditerranée c'est elle que je
trouve la plus agréable à manger parce
qu'on veut c'est pas l'ours est pas
riche c'est juste pleine saveur une
recette toute simple à préparer
ail oignon aubergines date pois chiches
noir gingembre et bien sûr hubert et est
ce que vous trouvez la même qualité
drogba pendant tout l'été
je dirais que la meilleure c'est la
première c'est papa l'a pas la toute
première c'est juste la deuxième quand
et tablettes ils ne sont pas trop grosse
à au moment de servir le chef ajoute
yogourt nature basilic et pistaches
c'est vraiment une très très bonne idée
et faire cette brique d'une armée avec
dallas québec pendant les deux saisons
de la rhubarbe j'essaye d'en acheter un
maximum et de les traiter pour les
conserver soit en purée soit un sirop
soit un coupé en morceaux sous marine et
sa puce mari très très bien c'est très
très bon mariné et ça se conserve super
bien
aussi facile que les betteraves ces
sucres un vinaigre blanc
moi je la roma tease à l'estragon pour
lui donner un peu de goût et de l'eau
c'est tout c'est une dose de sucre de
tosse de vinaigre à trois doses dont le
mieux c'est de le faire la veille
mais après ça on peut la mettre en pot
mason et la conserver au frigo
tous les versions en vie en fait c'est
vraiment un condiment mêmes utilisations
qu'on cornichons avec une viande grillée
la poissons grillés au barbecue ou même
à la table et là 24 heures plus tard sa
bedaine et ça ça donne ça rhubarbe
mariner dans une salade de tomates
voilà une combinaison surprenante mais ô
combien alléchante
ça c'est parfait si vous recevez des
amis à avec du barbecue de ricotta je
vais la mettre à la faig juste sur le
dessus comme ça quand les gens vont
aller manger pour reprendre sur le
dessus prendre la tomate et manger c'est
juste prendre celle ci est magnifique on
attend paul baehr de cuba des jeux
mondiaux mais je m'attendais a tellement
d'acidité aussi annulaire juristes y en
a le chef s'est aussi permis une
incursion dans l'univers sucré de la
rhubarbe
voici son éclair à la compote de
rhubarbe avec fraises fraîches et crème
chantilly c'est très bon d'autres choses
à découvrir
finalement prolonger la saison de la
rhubarbe
c'est aussi prolonger les plaisirs de la
table
e